no but the problem with North Korea is
there's no food no way no I've seen I've
seen videos
[Music]
so um
staffs staff shortages have been a thing
lately I've been hearing about staff
shortages yeah not here there's people
that's consciously trying to work at JK
and I gotta be like uh I can't barely
pay my own people maybe it's because
they got their staff shortaged in their
own regular life and they need to come
here because this is the bottom of the
barrel oh yeah yeah this is where people
come to kind of survive yeah
I guess of singers the Vegas of singers
everybody's like can I get a JK
residency because I'm 50 now I'm sorry
dude all right so there's a staff
shortage at a um high security prison
nice oh [__] and a Mafia Boss an Italian
mafia boss one of our favorites uh takes
advantage of this to escape using a
quote-unquote well-planned scheme
there's a slight video of it it's a it's
kind of interesting well according to
Johnny Chang trying to escape from jail
everyone laughs at you I guess it
depends on the prison though that's true
if it's life high security life maximum
if there's a high security prison that
has a staff shortage is it no longer
called a high security prison it's a
security it's a mid security these are
the questions that somebody should be
asking but I know it's not us
so as you can see the very classic
cartoon like no way he did the bed
sheets
sheets damn you got a Naruto run and
everything
damn dude your boss right there that's
the actual Mafia block yeah he didn't he
had regular clothes on let's tie it
maybe someone snuck it in he got a
civilian clothes
no the joggers closed they put Lululemon
in their butthole
dude that's expensive dude if I was in
prison and I say I want to escape and
people laughed at me I would think I
have a good
chance because they never believe you
they wouldn't believe it would happen
yeah no one's trying how would you do
would you get a spoon and carve out your
area I don't have the patience for that
oh so I would probably figure out like
the timing of everything damn I would
probably do that but he had to
disability but you would need a staff
shortage for that to work for sure oh
that would help like I would I would be
like oh staff shortage yeah you know
because then then you can eliminate
certain like um when they walk okay that
guy's not gonna be there but you know
people I think always mess up with like
I got out wait now what do I do yeah you
know so that's the key you got to have a
friend that's waiting or be a part of
like a crime syndicate yeah because
they'll they'll be they'll be the
getaway guy yeah yeah you got to go to a
non-extradition country you can't just
like but then even then you got to have
that homie that knows how to just
[__] fake passport for sure yeah yeah
you know what I mean that has for some
reason a security lock box that has a
gun and like a bunch of different U.S
currencies and [__] like that where
would you escape to
um
for sure not Korea because you know even
though they think Korea is good because
you could blend in no you could go to
North Korea you can go to North Korea
wow because that's they're not extra
dieting Americans no but the problem
with North Korea is there's no food no
way no I've seen I've seen videos
[Laughter]
their markets are popping I forgot I
forgot what country is not a tradition
I'm sure there's a company
yeah they're not really First Choice
places no but this I think there's a
couple in Europe uh like Russia Russia
because snowden's there yeah maybe
Russia be cool
at least they have food though in
certain places
caviar I feel like San Bernardino you
could go largest county in the world I
don't think they'll extradite you is it
it's the largest county in the world I
mean a lot of it is just shitland it's
pretty bad right now it's the myth
Capital here's this this says here are
seven countries to consider than a
non-extradition Morocco Indonesia Hong
Kong dude Morocco Morocco you can go to
Qatar Taiwan oh I would do I would do
Taiwan or home yeah I'd go to Hong Kong
dude Hong Kong would be cool guitar is
pretty awesome too right is it oh yeah
but we we you might be able to blend we
can't blame yeah but Hong Kong like a
blend yeah Hong Kong Taiwan I'll just
disappear into a night market never find
me again yeah you stick out like a sore
thumb bro like you would be the largest
they're like hey you want to be on a
physical 100 yeah
even like he'd be so good for like nine
years
[Laughter]
he was hanging out with a really really
tall Mexican lady you see two Federal
ages um like Passover 100 oh you won I
told you it would work dude I go to
Brazil Brazil would be cool because no
one will suspect Brazil
all right except for now but then
because I need to speak for after this
video I need to be close to a Japanese
Market oh there's such a huge Community
there's a lot that's true about Peru
yeah Lomo saltado with sushi dude that
sounds what about Jamaica and there's a
ton of Japanese people in Jamaica too
you might stick out in Jamaica though
not if I grow dreads that's true
according to something yeah Asian guy
with dreads never stands up
According to some people in the U.S uh
Joe you can go to Hawaii because it's a
different country oh yeah yeah according
to something
so this guy Mark it's like the whole
military there
this is a Marco radulano or whatever uh
has a long running criminal career as a
figure in the Sakura Corona Unita Mafia
in Italy uh in 2018 the 40 year old was
arrested as part of a drug and weapon
trafficking sting and then he earlier
this month received his final sentence
of 19 years behind bars uh putting him
in there until 2046. so he has to plan
that allowed to escape prison called
Badoo karos which is technically a high
security jail house in Sardinia a place
that was now once considered one of the
safest prisons in Italy surveillance
footage captures this that you guys just
saw just literally as as cliche as it
sounds he he tied bed sheets together
and nodded them and and literally waited
for the guard passing the exchanging of
prison guards and stuff like that during
a short staffed dude I bet uh Italian
prisons are pretty chill I don't I could
be completely wrong yeah because they're
all lazy do you think the stereotypes
and because they're all lazy I just feel
like they're laid back and they're just
like yeah whatever dude it's all good
dude they're just dipping bread and
olive oil being lazy talking all day
drinking coffee I just feel like they
live like differently they said they're
a country that lazy I forgot if it's
like Sweden or Switzerland or something
has some uh some law that escaping from
prison you don't get punished
or even attempting you don't get
punished because they said it's like a
human right to want to escape isn't that
like a secret Wink in the [__]
Constitution
have you seen
Scandinavian jails though Scandinavian
jails like they're they look like
Westfield
decorating their prisons well it makes
sense I mean it came from Sweden right
like yeah they probably got a bunch of
unsold stuff and they have a really good
mistakes yeah rehabilitation program
that's because they're so chill they're
so nice they're chilling there's a lot
of things that work in those countries
yeah they're like those Mexican prisons
where people go in and out constantly
the families live there
oh some of the Mexican prisons the the
uh the prisoners run it oh the guards
are just on the outside they don't go
inside at all so the prisoners run
everything like from the food to
everything everything that's pretty cool
yeah because if you watch the
documentary Gringo with Mel Gibson one
of the he's like one of the prisons
where families come no no one's seen
that no a lot of documentaries yeah
um I'm single I have a lot of time to to
watch things uh but yeah the families
come it's like a swap meet in there it's
like a flea market all set up no that's
cool man definitely definitely different
goodbye Shanks
remember when um that movie
um the the the the the Colombian cartel
man he he turned his prison into a
fortress and he just had like
prostitutes and like his friends in all
the time
um Colombian cartel man you talk about
like Pablo Escobar remember that show oh
narcos
[Laughter]
and he negotiated that with the
government yeah he had his own
jurisdiction you know that he's not even
that big if when you compare it to the
real big big guys and then this guy he
was on he's got a Netflix show
hey
apparently they want to be secret huh it
was just the DEA and all those guys
blowing them up and they're flamboyant
and loud but they're like there's
there's a guy that came out and he was
like the real dudes they're like
billionaires and they have like normal
companies like banana companies and all
that stuff makes sense yeah it's like
that great line in the documentary
Conspiracy Theory with Julia Roberts and
uh Mel Gibson
um the the richest man in the world had
just died the headline and they're like
he's not there like why are you saying
he's the richest man you know he's just
a regular rich guy and then Mel Gibson
goes if you were the richest man in the
world would you want people to know
exactly that's like a it's a total
poignant line like if you're one of the
richest cartels in the world why do you
want people to know you just kind of
just go under the radar they probably
don't have to live in hiding apparently
the cartels that like are by themselves
they can never go on vacation
they can never like leave the premises
because they're sort of wanted globally
but there's just no way to hide it with
celebritynetworth.com yep they got you
dude that is true they're so good man
they're there's a Cartoon Network
there's a cartelnetwork.com I believe
out there
[Music]